This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Andrew Leland has always loved to read. As a fifth grader, he was the kid who sat on a utility box during recess reading the Hobbit while everyone else played kickball. In middle school, he learned the trade names of the book imprints that published the drugie
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。安德鲁·利兰一直很喜欢阅读。五年级时，当其他孩子都在玩踢球游戏时，他总是坐在课间休息的配电箱上读《霍比特人》。在中学里，他学会了那些出版他开始接触的……
contemporary fiction that he was starting to get into. And in 2003, he dropped out of college and moved to San Francisco to work for his favorite publisher, McSweeney's. It was my dream job, and working there exacerbated my already intense fetish for print. That's Andrew. I got to live out my fantasy of being an ink stained wretch, even if that meant logging 12-hour days at an inkless computer. I edited essays and interviews, laid out articles,
当代小说的出版商的品牌名称。2003年，他从大学退学，搬到旧金山，为他最喜欢的出版商麦克斯威尼（McSweeney's）工作。“那是我的梦想工作，在那里工作加剧了我对印刷品本已强烈的迷恋。”那是安德鲁。“我得以实现了成为一个‘墨迹斑斑的苦力’的幻想，即使这意味着要在没有墨水的电脑前工作12个小时。”我编辑文章和采访，排版文章，
and took a weird amount of pleasure in typographical minutia, like italicizing commas and rewriting headlines so they fit the frame just so. At McSweeney's, books and magazines were never just containers for words. They were works of art onto themselves. And I was trained to take as much care with the look and feel of the print as I did with the expression
并从排版的细枝末节中获得了异乎寻常的快乐，比如把逗号改成斜体，重写标题以使其恰好适合版面。在麦克斯威尼，书籍和杂志从来不仅仅是文字的容器。它们本身就是艺术品。我受过训练，要像对待文本中思想的表达一样，对印刷品的外观和质感给予同样的关注。
of the ideas in the text. But as much as Andrew loved print, he still loves it, in fact, he also has a condition that will eventually change his relationship to it pretty radically. I'm going blind, really, really slowly. Right now, it's like I've got a foot in both worlds, blind and sighted. I have it a generative retinal disease that's given me severe tunnel vision, so basically no peripheral vision. It's like I'm peering at the world through a toilet paper tube, one that gets a little narrower every few months. 10
但尽管安德鲁热爱印刷品——事实上他现在依然热爱——他还有一种疾病，这种疾病最终会彻底改变他与印刷品的关系。“我正在失明，非常、非常缓慢地失明。现在，我感觉自己的一只脚跨在两个世界里：盲人和视力正常者的世界。我患有一种遗传性视网膜疾病，导致了严重的管状视野，基本上没有周边视觉。就像我正透过一根卫生纸筒窥视世界，而且每隔几个月，这个筒就会变得更窄一点。”
Alright, I'm going to try to read this and then see if I got it right. Can we... My retinal specialist told me that I probably don't need to worry about losing the ability to read for another five years or so, but I've already started using a special digital program to learn Braille, which is not easy. Be cocky. What? I want to get a jump-starting before I actually need it. Recru...recuckly...what?
“好吧，我要试着读一下这个，看看我读得对不对。我们可以……我的视网膜专家告诉我，我可能在未来五年左右都不需要担心失去阅读能力，但我已经开始使用一个特殊的数字程序来学习盲文，这并不容易。要自信。什么？我想在真正需要之前先起个头。Recru...recuckly...什么？”
A recycle. Can we recycle a metal can? I know I'll still be able to experience books for the rest of my life. I'm lucky to be going blind in the digital age and the golden age of audio. There's an abundance of well-produced audio books and technology that can read aloud almost anything that appears on a screen. Puzzles? My niece can ride a unicycle or a duped puzzles? My niece can ride a unicycle or do puzzles. My niece can ride a unicycle or do puzzles. What the fuck does that mean?
“回收。我们可以回收金属罐吗？我知道我余生依然能够体验书籍。我很幸运能在数字时代和音频的黄金时代失明。现在有大量制作精良的有声读物和几乎可以朗读屏幕上任何内容的科技。拼图？我侄女会骑独轮车或者做拼图？我侄女会骑独轮车或者做拼图。我侄女会骑独轮车或者做拼图。这到底是什么意思？”
My niece can do no such thing. But despite all that, there's still some mellow tragedy in the idea that in a few years, I'll probably no longer be able to read print. After a life-spent loving books, there's now a real urgency for me in the question of how blind people experience literature. I find myself deeply curious about what graphic design might mean to someone who can't see, and so I started looking into the history of reading technologies for the blind. Traditionally, books are visual objects, and for centuries now, blind and sighted designers have been arguing over the most effective
“我侄女根本不会做那种事。”但尽管如此，想到几年后我可能再也无法阅读印刷品，心中仍有一种淡淡的悲剧感。在经历了一生对书籍的热爱之后，关于盲人如何体验文学的问题对我来说变得非常紧迫。我对自己深感好奇：对于一个看不见的人来说，平面设计意味着什么？于是我开始研究盲人阅读技术的历史。传统上，书籍是视觉对象，几个世纪以来，盲人和视力正常的各种设计师一直在争论最有效的……
way to translate the visual ink print book into an accessible form for people without sight. For as long as blind people have been reading, there's been this tension between systems that try to stay close to the original form of a book and systems that dramatically depart from our ideas of what a book can be. Cited designers have made incredible breakthroughs to create non-visual forms of reading for blind people. But as one blind critic pointed out, Cited designers have a bad habit of, quote, talking to the
将视觉墨印书籍转化为盲人可获取形式的方法。只要盲人一直在阅读，在试图保持书籍原始形式的系统和彻底背离我们对书籍定义概念的系统之间，就一直存在着这种张力。视力正常的设计师们在为盲人创造非视觉阅读形式方面取得了令人难以置信的突破。但正如一位盲人评论家所指出的，视力正常的设计师有一个坏习惯，即“用眼睛的语言与手指对话”。
fingers in the language of the eyes. So the history of blind reading is really the history of finding a new language for the fingers and for the ears, one that captures the essential elements of the ink print book, but in a new language that's unbound from the visual. And that history centers around two main shapes, lines and dots. Our story starts in 18th century Europe before Braille was invented, before blind people were even taught to read at all.
所以盲人阅读的历史，实际上是为手指和耳朵寻找一种新语言的历史，这种语言捕捉了墨印书籍的基本要素，但却是一种脱离了视觉的新语言。这段历史围绕着两种主要形状展开：线条和点。我们的故事始于18世纪的欧洲，在盲文发明之前，甚至在盲人被教导阅读之前。
First off, no one thinks that it's possible for bond kids to learn. That's Mike Hudson, the museum director at the American printing house for the blind in Louisville, Kentucky. And if they could, no one knows how to do it. Without access to education, blind people were overwhelmingly poor, and their employment prospects were dim. If their families had enough money and time to support them, they usually lived at home, like adult children sitting idly around the house.
“首先，没人认为盲童有可能学习。”那是迈克·哈德森，肯塔基州路易斯维尔美国盲人印刷厂的博物馆馆长。“即使他们能学，也没人知道该怎么教。”由于无法接受教育，盲人绝大多数都很贫穷，就业前景黯淡。如果他们的家庭有足够的金钱和时间支持他们，他们通常会住在家里，就像成年孩子一样整天无所事事地待在屋里。
Many others were forced to beg on the street. There were a handful of institutions in Europe to support the poorest cases, but they pitted the blind and hid them away from public view. But then this guy named Valentin Awee comes along. Awee was born into a family of weavers in France and he was a skilled linguist. He was first inspired to help the blind in 1771. We saw a group of blind people being mocked during a street festival in Paris. They had been given dunce caps and giant fake glasses and they were made to play musical instruments and pretend to read books. So how we founded the first known school for the blind.
许多其他人被迫在街上乞讨。欧洲有少数机构支持最贫困的案例，但他们把盲人关起来，让他们远离公众视线。但后来，一个叫瓦伦丁·阿维（Valentin Haüy）的人出现了。阿维出生在法国一个织布工家庭，是一位精通语言的人。他第一次产生帮助盲人的想法是在1771年。我们看到一群盲人在巴黎的街头节日中被嘲笑。他们被戴上傻瓜帽，戴上巨大的假眼镜，被迫演奏乐器并假装阅读书籍。于是阿维创办了第一所已知的盲人学校。
It was called the Royal Institute in Paris. But even as he's getting the school going, how we kept a side gig. And a wheeze side gig is as a translator for the King of France. And so every now and then you'll get these fancy embossed invitations to various events. And one day, one of our we students, a kid named Francois LeSour, touched one of them. And Francois LeSour notices that he can feel something
它被称为巴黎皇家盲人学院。但即使在学校创办之初，阿维也有一份副业。阿维的副业是法国国王的翻译。所以时不时地，你会收到这些印有精美浮雕的活动邀请函。有一天，阿维的一名学生，一个叫弗朗索瓦·勒苏尔（Francois Lesueur）的孩子，摸到了其中一张。弗朗索瓦·勒苏尔注意到他能感觉到……
on these invitations. And that gives our we the idea, the idea to develop this idea of embossed printing in raised letters. So in 1786, our we makes the first machine embossed book for the blind. A treatise on blind education. It's written in print, the kind that cited readers would recognise, but the text is all raised so that blind students can feel the shape of the letters. And it's a radical move, not just the first book for blind readers in history, but basically the beginning of the idea that blind people can be educated.
这些邀请函上有些东西。这给了阿维灵感，让他萌生了开发这种凸起字母浮雕印刷的想法。于是，在1786年，阿维制作了第一本为盲人制作的机器浮雕书。这是一篇关于盲人教育的论文。它用的是印刷体，那种视力正常的读者能认出的字体，但文字全部凸起，以便盲人学生能摸出字母的形状。这是一个激进的举动，不仅是历史上第一本为盲人读者准备的书，基本上也是盲人可以接受教育这一理念的开端。
But there are a few problems. Well, first off, no one can afford to buy these books. Okay. That's because the books are massive and prohibitively expensive, but they're also just really hard to read. They're filled with ornate 18th-century letterforms with their curly cues and flourishes which are confusing to the fingertips. It's not until many years later, near the end of Awe's life in 1821, that a very different
但有几个问题。好吧，首先，没人买得起这些书。那是由于这些书体积庞大，价格高得令人望而却步，而且它们真的很难读。它们充满了18世纪华丽的字母形式，带有卷曲和装饰，这让指尖感到困惑。直到多年后，在阿维生命接近尾声的1821年，一种非常不同的……
blind reading system begins to develop, one that uses dots instead of lines. It starts when a captain from Napoleon's army visits the school to share a system that he developed for French soldiers. The captain describes how the system allowed his men to silently communicate with each other on battlefields at night. This is a clip from a very lively educational movie about this history. The director of the school at the time led a group of students experiment with the embossed
盲人阅读系统开始发展，一种使用点而不是线的系统。它始于拿破仑军队的一位上尉访问学校，分享他为法国士兵开发的一套系统。这位上尉描述了该系统如何让他的士兵在夜间的战场上进行无声交流。这是一段关于这段历史的非常生动的教育电影片段。当时的校长带领一群学生尝试了那位上尉留下的浮雕……
pages that the captain had left behind, and in that group was a 12-year-old blind kid, named Louie Braille. Over the next few years, he began to adapt that military code for blind people as an alternative to raised print. Louis, you've been working on that for days. Your mother's worried. Can't you take a break? No, I am so close.
页面，在那群学生中，有一个12岁的盲童，名叫路易·布莱叶（Louis Braille）。在接下来的几年里，他开始将那种军事代码改编为盲人使用的系统，作为凸起印刷体的替代品。“路易，你已经为此工作好几天了。你母亲很担心。你不能休息一下吗？”“不，我快成功了。”
I've got it worked out so that all the letters of the alphabet are represented by raised dots in different combinations. Louis Braille simplified the military code and maximized its efficiency. He substituted the 12-dot system developed by the captain into a 6-dot system, which allowed blind people to read faster by recognizing a letter with the touch of a single finger. And while this code was inscrutable to sighted people, it was the system that blind people needed, designed by a blind person who understood intimately the needs of those reading by touch.
“我已经算出来了，字母表中的所有字母都由不同组合的凸点表示。”路易·布莱叶简化了军事代码并最大化了其效率。他将上尉开发的12点系统替换为6点系统，这使得盲人可以通过单指触摸识别字母来更快地阅读。虽然这种代码对视力正常的人来说是不可理解的，但它正是盲人所需要的系统，由一位深刻理解触摸阅读者需求的盲人所设计。
Another advocate for the blind would say of Braille, it bears the stamp of genius, like the Roman alphabet itself. But despite its effectiveness, Braille didn't catch on right away. It wouldn't become the dominant system in France for another 30 years, and it'd be nearly a century before it became standard for blind readers in the US. Because it was effectively suppressed by a well-intentioned world-famous visionary of blind education. Around the same time that Braille was quietly developing his new reading system, an American named Samuel Gridley Howe came to visit the Royal Institute in France. He was doing research and anticipation of opening the first school for the blind in the
另一位盲人倡导者曾这样评价布莱叶盲文：“它带有天才的印记，就像罗马字母表本身一样。”但尽管它很有效，布莱叶盲文并没有立即流行起来。它在法国花了30年才成为主流系统，而在美国成为盲人读者的标准则花了近一个世纪。因为它实际上被一位动机良好、世界闻名的盲人教育远见者所压制。就在布莱叶悄悄开发他的新阅读系统时，一位名叫塞缪尔·格里德利·豪（Samuel Gridley Howe）的美国人来到法国皇家学院参观。他当时正在进行研究，为在美国开设第一所盲人学校做准备……
U.S. And I wish I could tell you that while in France how discovered the wonders of Braille, but that's not how it went down. Instead he saw the raised letter books and he was intrigued, but in true American fashion, he found all their fancy flourishes, impractical, and typical of European excess. So he decided to make his own system that improved on the Europeans work. And he came back and he modified it a bit. That's Kim Charlson, the director of the library at the Perkins School, which Howe established in Massachusetts in 1829.
“我真希望我能告诉你，豪在法国发现了布莱叶盲文的奇妙之处，但事实并非如此。”相反，他看到了凸起字母的书籍，并对此产生了兴趣，但以典型的美国方式，他发现那些华丽的装饰既不实用，又是典型的欧洲式铺张。于是他决定制作自己的系统，改进欧洲人的工作。他回来后做了一些修改。那是金·查尔森（Kim Charlson），珀金斯盲人学校图书馆馆长，豪于1829年在马萨诸塞州创办了该校。
Because they were using a more gothic style font that he felt was a little too ornamental and more difficult to read by touch. So if one of our wee's French books looked sort of like an ancient home in a horror movie whose letters rise up in fleshy pertuberances, then House System is similar, but it looks more runic, tokeny, elvish. How sharpened his letters curves into points to make them more distinct under the fingertips. The letter O, for example, is shaped like a diamond.
“因为他们使用的是一种更哥特式的字体，他觉得这种字体装饰性太强，用触摸阅读更困难。”所以，如果阿维的法文书看起来像恐怖电影里的古老房屋，字母像肉质突起一样升起，那么豪的系统也类似，但看起来更像符文、托尔金风格或精灵语。豪将字母的曲线磨尖成点，使它们在指尖下更清晰。例如，字母O被塑造成菱形。
How calls his new system Boston Line Type? Boston Line Type is really the beginning of literacy as we know it as a movement for people who are blind in the United States. And like the older French system, Boston Line Type was designed to be read both by blind and sighted people. And if you're able to see and look at one of these books, the letters are totally easily legible. Boston Line Type allows blind people and sighted people to sit down together and to read.
豪将他的新系统称为“波士顿线体”（Boston Line Type）。“波士顿线体确实是我们所知的美国盲人运动中识字教育的开端。”和较早的法国系统一样，波士顿线体被设计为既能被盲人也能被视力正常的人阅读。如果你能看见并看这些书中的一本，这些字母是完全容易辨认的。波士顿线体允许盲人和视力正常的人坐在一起阅读。
There's no barrier between them. And this idea was really important to how. He didn't want blind people to use a system, like Braille, that was separate from what sighted people used. He thought it would isolate blind people and prevent them from integrating into the wider world. Long before the concept of universal design had been articulated,
他们之间没有障碍。这个想法对豪来说非常重要。他不想让盲人使用像布莱叶盲文那样与视力正常者所使用的系统分开的系统。他认为这会孤立盲人，并阻止他们融入更广阔的世界。在“通用设计”概念被阐述很久之前，
it was informing how's thinking about how to design for people with disabilities. I know so, you can imagine the argument. Well, we want our kids that are blind and visual impaired to use the same system that our cited kids use, right? That sounds good, right? But it turns out that raise letters are just not as good as a Braille. Why not? the same system that our sided kids use, right? That sounds good, right? But it turns out that raise letters
它就已经在影响豪关于如何为残疾人进行设计的思考。“我知道，所以你可以想象这种争论。‘好吧，我们希望我们的盲人和视力受损的孩子使用和我们视力正常的孩子一样的系统，对吧？这听起来不错，对吧？’但事实证明，凸起字母就是不如布莱叶盲文好。为什么不呢？……和我们视力正常的孩子使用一样的系统，对吧？这听起来不错，对吧？但事实证明，凸起字母……”
are just not as good as a braille. Why not? So it's harder. It just is harder. That's not intuitive to people who are sided, but those letter forms are just not unique enough from each other. Sided people look at braille and they go,
“就是不如布莱叶盲文好。为什么不呢？”“所以它更难。它就是更难。这对视力正常的人来说并不直观，但那些字母形式彼此之间不够独特。”视力正常的人看着布莱叶盲文，他们会说，
oh, it all looks the same. But under the finger, those raised dots dots underneath your finger are just more tangible. Okay, they just auger. And not only that, you can write in braille. I'm like raised print. It doesn't require a big heavy metal printing press. All you need is a small, simple tool called a slate and stylus that fits in your pocket. By the 1860s, some schools of the blind in the US had begun experimenting with Braille, and while many faculty members still resisted it as an arbitrary, impenetrable system, the blind students who were exposed to Braille argued passionately for its superiority to
“哦，看起来都一样。”但在手指下，那些凸点——你手指下的那些点——确实更具触感。好吧，它们只是……而且不仅如此，你可以用布莱叶盲文书写。不像凸起印刷体，它不需要一台笨重的大型金属印刷机。你只需要一个放在口袋里的小巧简单的工具，叫做盲文板和笔。到了1860年代，美国的一些盲人学校已经开始尝试布莱叶盲文，虽然许多教职员工仍然抵制它，认为它是一个武断、难以理解的系统，但接触过布莱叶盲文的盲人学生却热情地为它的优越性辩护……
raised letters. At the Missouri School for the Blind, students passed each other notes and reportedly even love letters in Braille since they knew their teachers wouldn't be able to read them if they got caught. But how had invested a massive amount of time and resources into developing, distributing, and promoting Boston Line Type? And he'd become a hugely influential celebrity
反对凸起字母。在密苏里盲人学校，学生们互相传递纸条，据报道甚至用布莱叶盲文写情书，因为他们知道如果被抓到，老师们将无法阅读它们。但豪在开发、分发和推广波士顿线体上投入了大量的时间和资源。他已经成为盲人教育领域一位极具影响力的名人。
in the field of blind education. He was a master fundraiser, and key to that fundraising apparatus was the spectacle of a deaf blind girl named Laura Bridgeman, who how taught to read using Boston Lines Type. Bridgeman was the first deaf blind person in history to get an education, more than a full generation before Helen Keller did. This achievement made Laura Bridgeman and how, international stars, which Howe leveraged to make Boston Line Type one of the dominant print mediums for the blind across the US. Like Howe, many of the directors and faculty at schools for the blind were cited, and many
他是一位筹款大师，而筹款机制的关键是一个名叫劳拉·布里奇曼（Laura Bridgeman）的聋盲女孩的奇观，豪用波士顿线体教她阅读。布里奇曼是历史上第一个接受教育的聋盲人，比海伦·凯勒早了整整一代人。这一成就使劳拉·布里奇曼和豪成为了国际明星，豪利用这一点使波士顿线体成为美国盲人最主要的印刷媒介之一。像豪一样，许多盲人学校的校长和教职员工都是视力正常的，他们中的许多人……
of them believed that they knew which system was best. Well, it's easy for me reading a print letter, so it's going to be easy for them with their fingers, you know, and he'd I think it's a failure of imagination or a failure of empathy or a failure of experience. Catherine Cudlick directs the Paul K. Longmore Institute on Disability at San Francisco State, where she's also a history professor, and she doesn't even really buy house argument that Boston Line Type was universal. You might have thought of this universal, but it's universal in that way that the colonizer thinks, thinks are universal.
相信他们知道哪个系统最好。“好吧，对我来说读印刷字母很容易，所以对他们用手指来说也会很容易，你知道，我认为这是想象力的失败，或者是同理心的失败，或者是经验的失败。”凯瑟琳·库德利克（Catherine Cudlick）在旧金山州立大学指导保罗·K·朗莫尔残疾研究所，她也是那里的历史学教授，她甚至不太相信豪关于波士顿线体是通用的论点。“你可能认为这是通用的，但它是在殖民者认为事物是通用的那种方式下的通用。”
It's like, you know, these poor native peoples need educating and we'll try to bring them up to my level and make them like me. They didn't get the blind people to be the experts. There's a crucial part is, I mean, that's like a disability, rights refrain is nothing. Nothing about us without us, yeah. In fact, the new way that people are starting to say it is nothing without us. Period. I think how probably made a good faith effort to create a universal system,
“就像，你知道，这些可怜的土著人民需要教育，我们会试着把他们提升到我的水平，让他们变得像我一样。”他们没有让盲人成为专家。这是一个关键部分，我的意思是，这就像残疾人权利运动的口号：没有我们的参与，不要做关于我们的决定。“是的。事实上，人们开始说的新方式是：没有我们，什么都别做。句号。”我认为豪可能确实是出于好意，试图创造一个通用系统，
one that predicted universal design, one that he hoped would have raised the line dividing the blind from the sighted. But paradoxically, in committing so strongly to the universal page of Boston line type, how helped delay the adoption of a much better system by close to a hundred years in the US. A system where the blind person, Louis Braille, was the expert. By the early 20th century, how had died. There were growing numbers of organizations dedicated to serving the blind, and more and more of them were being led by blind people. In 1921, leaders from the most influential of these groups gathered in rural Iowa to form
一个预示了通用设计的系统，一个他希望能够消除盲人和视力正常者之间界限的系统。但矛盾的是，由于对波士顿线体的通用页面投入如此之大，豪在客观上帮助推迟了美国采用一种好得多的系统近一百年。那是一个由盲人路易·布莱叶作为专家的系统。到了20世纪初，豪已经去世。致力于服务盲人的组织越来越多，其中越来越多的组织由盲人领导。1921年，这些最具影响力的团体的领导人在爱荷华州农村聚集，成立了……
the American Foundation for Blind. The AFB quickly became the most powerful blindness organization in the US, and one of their first priorities was to make Braille, the dominant system. But, Americans being Americans, the same thing happened that it happened with raised letters. We decided that we could design things better than those pretentious Europeans could. So a whole cottage industry arose, with all sorts of competing systems. Braille knockoffs. So, now we're heading into what we call the War of the Dots. Have you heard of that? We could spend an entire episode on the War of the Dots with Mike Hudson as our trusting narrator,
美国盲人基金会（AFB）。AFB很快成为美国最强大的盲人组织，他们的首要任务之一就是使布莱叶盲文成为主流系统。但是，美国人毕竟是美国人，同样的事情发生了，就像凸起字母发生的那样。我们决定我们可以比那些自命不凡的欧洲人设计得更好。于是出现了一个完整的家庭手工业，各种相互竞争的系统。布莱叶盲文的仿制品。所以，现在我们要进入所谓的“点字战争”。你听说过吗？我们可以用一整集来讲述“点字战争”，由迈克·哈德森担任我们值得信赖的叙述者，
but in a nutshell, before Braille truly won out in the US, there was another 50 years of competing tactile systems. This period drove many blind readers bananas because every library for the blind was filled with books printed in these multiple competing systems. New York Point, Moon type, American modified Braille. There are others, by the way. We're not going to go into them. But at one point, the head of the Perkins school says, you know, if anybody invents another code for the blind, we want to shoot them on the spot. Ha ha ha. The decisive battle in the war of the dots finally came in 1909. Cities like New York were rapidly growing,
但简而言之，在布莱叶盲文真正赢得美国市场之前，还有50年的时间里存在着相互竞争的触觉系统。这段时期让许多盲人读者抓狂，因为每个盲人图书馆都挤满了用这些多种相互竞争的系统印刷的书籍。纽约点字、月亮体、美国改良布莱叶盲文。顺便说一句，还有其他的。我们就不一一细说了。但有一次，珀金斯学校的校长说，你知道，如果还有人发明另一种盲人代码，我们想当场枪毙他们。哈哈。点字战争的决定性战役最终发生在1909年。像纽约这样的城市正在迅速发展，
and for the first time, they had enough blind children to start building day schools for the blind. And so they have a nice big, two day knockdown, drag out meeting of the New York Board of Education to decide which code they're going to use in the New York City schools. So they bring in all the heavy hitters. Okay.
并且第一次，他们有了足够的盲童来开始建立盲人日间学校。于是，他们在纽约教育委员会进行了一场精彩的、为期两天的激烈会议，以决定他们将在纽约市学校使用哪种代码。所以他们请来了所有重量级人物。好吧。
I mean, everybody's anybody in line is testifies before this body. And at the end, they take a big vote, and they vote for Braille. Okay? It's the beginning of the end for the competing codes. By 1917, the rest of the country follows New York's lead, and the newly standardized English Braille becomes the main way blind children are taught to read in the US. And with their increasing self-determination and literacy, blind people are more able to integrate into society than ever before. Blind children are starting to be mainstreamed into
我的意思是，所有盲人领域的重要人物都在这个机构面前作证。最后，他们进行了一次大投票，他们投票支持布莱叶盲文。好吧？这是相互竞争的代码走向终结的开始。到1917年，全国其他地区跟随纽约的脚步，新标准化的英语布莱叶盲文成为美国盲童学习阅读的主要方式。随着他们自我决定能力和识字能力的提高，盲人比以往任何时候都更能融入社会。盲童开始被主流化到……
public schools, and for the first time, some blind people are getting office jobs using tech-like Braille typewriter so they can work alongside-sided people, as equals. It's what how had hoped Boston line-type would help them do. But for all Braille's advantages over raised print, it didn't work for all blind people. Like the thousands of soldiers who were coming back from war with eye injuries, who hadn't learned Braille as kids. And as you probably noticed, listening to me struggle to read that stupid sentence about my niece doing puzzles. Puzzles?
公立学校，并且第一次，一些盲人开始使用类似布莱叶盲文打字机的技术获得办公室工作，这样他们就可以作为平等的人与视力正常的人一起工作。这正是豪希望波士顿线体能帮助他们做到的。但尽管布莱叶盲文比凸起印刷体有诸多优势，它并不适用于所有盲人。比如成千上万从战争中归来、眼睛受伤的士兵，他们小时候并没有学过布莱叶盲文。正如你可能注意到的，听我努力阅读那句关于我侄女做拼图的愚蠢句子。拼图？
My niece can write a unicycle or a dupe of puzzles. Puzzles? Puzzles? By niece can ride a unicycle or a dupe puzzles. Learning Braille as an adult is really hard. My niece can ride a unicycle or dupe puzzles. But as sound recording became easier and more affordable, those people who'd become blind later in life had new options. Options that would transform our ideas of what a book can be. Translating inkprint books into sound might seem more straightforward than building a tactile reading system. After all, books were born out of a few thousand years of people telling
“我侄女会骑独轮车或者做拼图。拼图？拼图？我侄女会骑独轮车或者做拼图。”成年后学习布莱叶盲文真的很难。“我侄女会骑独轮车或者做拼图。”但随着录音变得更容易、更实惠，那些后来失明的人有了新的选择。这些选择将改变我们对书籍定义的看法。将墨印书籍翻译成声音似乎比建立触觉阅读系统更直接。毕竟，书籍诞生于几千年来人们互相讲述故事的过程中，我们都是通过听别人读书学会阅读的。但早期为盲人读者制作书籍录音的努力带来了一系列新的设计挑战。美国盲人基金会与卡内基公司合作，在唱片上出版实验性书籍。他们称之为“有声书”（Talking Books）。他们聘请了叙述者，并将录音压制在长篇唱片上，每面25分钟。
each other stories, and we all learned to read by having books read to us. But early efforts to make recordings of books for blind readers brought with them a new set of design challenges. The American Foundation for the Blind partnered with the Carnegie Corporation to publish experimental books on phonographic records. They called them talking books. They hired narrators and pressed the recordings onto long-playing records, 25 minutes aside.
这些书籍在LP唱片向大众普及前大约十年就开始在盲人中流传。第一批有声读物和第一批LP唱片是为盲人读者制作的。但这些有声书提出了重大问题。一本书听起来应该是什么样的？你如何翻译法典（Codex）的要素，这是一个花哨的词，指我们通常称之为带有纸页、墨水和装订的书的东西。你如何将其中一种东西翻译成声音？书籍的定义在这些有声书开始开发后几乎崩溃了，因为各种各样的制作人开始想出新的想法，称之为有声书，而这些东西肯定与法典形式无关。那是玛拉·米尔斯（Mara Mills）。她是纽约大学的教授，在媒体和残疾研究的交叉领域工作。我保证她是最后一位我要向你介绍的学者。
These books were circulated by blind people about a decade before LPs became available to the wider public. The first audio books and the first LPs were made for blind readers. But these talking books raised big questions. What should a book sound like? How do you translate the elements of a codex, which is a fancy word for the thing
让我们暂停一下我们的章节，听听它像歌曲一样带来反馈。例如，康奈尔鸟类学实验室决定，他们想把他们的一些鸟鸣录音拿出来，为盲人制作一本有声书。它们是美国鸟类中最优美的，它们竞争……当《白雪公主》作为早期的动画有声电影上映时，AFB决定他们想制作一个有声电影的有声书版本。沃尔特·迪斯尼的《白雪公主和七个小矮人》，专门为盲人录制。没有书籍原型。
that we usually call a book with paper pages, ink, and binding. How do you translate one of those things into sound? The definition of the book basically imploded right after these talking books started to be developed, because all sorts of producers started to come up with new ideas for things that they would call talking books that certainly had nothing to do with the Codex form. That's Mara Mills. She's professor at NYU who works at the intersection of media and disability studies. And I promise she's the last academic I'm going to introduce you to.
他们称之为书，并作为有声书发行，但它是对动画电影中图像的音频描述，并配有电影中的一些声音文件和对话。“猎人，快跑，快跑！当你就在白雪公主身后时，他拔出了他的大刀，然后白雪公主注意到地上的影子。”很快，各种各样的东西开始被称为书，而它们与书籍形式的关系非常微弱。随着有声书变得越来越精致和戏剧化，充满了音效……
Let's piece our chapter for a minute and listen to it bringing the feedback like songs. The Cornell Ornithology Lab, for instance, decided that they wanted to take some of their bird song recordings and make a talking book for blind people out of them. They're wrong to the mongda finest of American birds, and they rival and perhaps the past when Snow White came out as an early animated talking movie, the AFB decided they wanted to make a talking book version of a talking movie. Walt Disney's Snow White and the Seven Wolves recorded solely for the use of the line. There was no book origin.
和音乐，一些盲人感到沮丧。越来越多的盲人读者最终弄坏了他们的唱片机，试图加快叙述者的语速。他们听书不是为了声音的美学享受。他们想要该死的信息，而那些花哨的制作对于他们想要阅读的速度来说太慢了。这与人们以双倍速度听播客的冲动是一样的。
They called it a book and they circulated it as a talking book, but it was a audio description of the images in an animated film with some of the sound files and dialogue from that film. The Huntsman, Kripp, Coser, and Coser. How pretend you are! When he was right behind Snow White, he drew his big night, then Snow White noticed a shadow on the ground. Very quickly, all sorts of things began to be called books that had very marginal relationship to the book form. And as talking books became more elaborate and theatrical, more filled with sound effects
正如凸起字母书籍一样，音乐和音效的华丽装饰阻碍了盲人对速度的渴望。于是有声书开始听起来不同了。《圣经》，钦定版。由亚历山大·斯考比（Alexander Scourby）朗读。像亚历山大·斯考比这样不废话的叙述者在1940和50年代变得更受欢迎。
and music, some blind people grew frustrated. More and more blind readers wound up breaking their record players trying to speed up the voices of the narrators. They weren't listening for sonic aesthetic pleasure. They wanted to dam information, and the fancy productions moved too slowly for how fast they wanted to read. Which is the same impulse that makes people listen to podcasts at double speed.
他们的声音几乎变成了字体，标准化、易读，最重要的是，在不碍事的情况下传达信息，更像当代有声读物的叙述者。“起初，神创造天地。”当代有声读物的叙述者。书籍历史学家马修·鲁伯里（Matthew Rubery）告诉我，如果你向一位一定年龄的盲人提起亚历山大·斯考比的名字，他们的眼睛会因为对他声音的联想而充满泪水。
As with raised letter books, the ornamental flourishes of music and sound effects got in the way of blind people's desire for speed. And so talking books began to sound different. The holy Bible, the King James V. Read by Alexander Storvey. No nonsense narrators, like Alexander Skorby, became more popular in the 1940s and 50s.
他们从小听着他的声音长大，读着他的书。所以，也许这就是我成为盲人读者后的慰藉。我可以把视觉字体换成口头字体。“让水中有穹苍，将水分为上下。”在某些方面，我对失去与书籍视觉关系的恐惧，类似于视力正常的人对数字时代印刷品消亡的焦虑。随着越来越多的人在屏幕上阅读，有一群老派人士哀叹这些新的阅读形式是低劣的。这些评论家认为，书籍这种可靠的旧技术永远是思想的优越载体。
And their voices became almost like fonts, standardized, legible, and, most importantly, conveying information without getting in the way, more like the narrators of contemporary audiobooks. In the beginning, God created the heaven and the earth. the narrators of contemporary audiobooks. The book historian Matthew Rubery told me that if you bring up the name Alexander's scoreby with a blind person of a certain age, their eyes will fill with tears because of the associations they have with his voice.
你不仅可以从那些贬低电子书的人那里听到这种保守主义和屈尊俯就，还可以从那些说如果你听书就不算真正读过书的人的声音中听到。他们认为真正的阅读只发生在眼睛上。但盲人和阅读的历史表明，我们的阅读方式一直处于变动之中。我交谈过的媒体学者和书籍历史学家都告诉了我同样的事情。阅读不是发生在眼睛、耳朵或手指上。它发生在脑子里。
They grew up listening to him, reading him. So perhaps this is my consolation as I become a blind reader. I can just trade a visual typeface for a verbal one. Let there be a firmament in the midst of the waters and let it divide the waters from the waters. In some ways, my fears about losing my visual relationship to books resembles the anxieties that sighted people have about the demise of print in the digital age. As more and more people read on screens, there's an old guard who bemoans these new forms of reading as inferior. These critics believe that the trusty old technology of the book will always be the superior vehicle for ideas.
如果你正在失明，这是一个好消息。这让我觉得，忘掉我那愚蠢的眼睛吧。我依然拥有我的大脑，反正所有美好的事情都发生在那里。但这个想法并不能真正减轻或掩盖失明不可避免地是一种损失的事实。没有任何历史研究或概念重构可以掩盖这里简单的等式。我热爱书籍，热爱带有页边注、字体和装饰符号的墨印书籍，而失明将夺走这一切。
You can hear this conservatism and condescension, not only in those people who align the e-book, but also in the voices of people who say that you haven't really read a book if you listen to it. They contend that real reading only happens with the eyes. But the history of blindness and reading shows that the way we read has always been in flux. The media scholars and book historians I talked to all told me the same thing. Reading doesn't happen in the eyes or the ears or the fingers. It happens in the brain.
但我不能让这成为我唯一的结论，即失明等于损失，句号。玛拉·米尔斯告诉我她遇到的一个人，他的故事可以为我提供一个以不同方式对待我盲人读者生活的例子。他的名字是哈维·劳尔（Harvey Lauer）。他是一位盲人，在退伍军人事务部工作，测试各种为视障人士提供的技术。“当你打开机器时，你会听到耳机里的所有声音。”这是哈维在使用一种光音器（Optophone），一种扫描仪，它会观察文本并将其转化为一系列代表字母形状的音调。这是为盲人读者进行通用设计的另一种尝试。有了光音器，你根本不需要为盲人制作特殊的书籍。
And this is a nice thing to hear if you're going blind. It makes me feel like, forget my stupid eyes. I'll still have my brain, and that's where all the good stuff happens anyway. But this idea doesn't really soften or mask the fact that blindness is inescapably a loss. No amount of historical research or conceptual reframing can hide the simple equation at work here. I love books, ink print books, with marginalia and typefaces and dingbats, and going blind will take that away from me.
通过训练，盲人可以使用这些设备阅读墨印书籍。光音器最早开发于1912年，但这录音来自1971年。阅读听起来像这样。“首先，找到行。然后我们开始读。”令人难以置信的是，一些盲人确实学会了这种阅读方式。经过大量练习，他们可以听到这些声音并解码它们所代表的单词。
But I can't let that be my only conclusion, that blindness equals loss full stop. Mara Mills told me about someone she met, whose story could offer me an example of a different way to approach my life as a blind reader. His name is Harvey Lauer. He's a blind guy who worked at the VA, testing all kinds of technology for the visually impaired. When you turn on the machine, you hear all the sounds in the earphone. This is Harvey using an optophone, a kind of scanner, that would look at text and turn it into a series of tones representing the shapes of the letters. It's another spin on universal design for blind readers. With an optophone, you wouldn't need to create special books for the blind at all.
阅读整部小说，使用所谓的“音乐印刷体”。这是必要的函数……使用他在退伍军人事务部测试的设备，哈维可以通过音乐印刷体的振动进行阅读，加上布莱叶盲文和超高速有声书。他比地球上任何人都更多地利用他的身体、更多的感官进行阅读。他的同事称他为“半机械人”。他走到哪里都带着这些挂在脖子上的设备，发出振动和合成的音乐音调。
With training, a blind person could read an inkprint book using one of these devices. The optophone was first developed in 1912, but this recording is from 1971. Reading sounds like this. First off, find the line. And then we'll read. Incredibly, some blind people actually learned how to read this way. After a lot of practice, they could hear these sounds and decode the words they represented.
“我不得不调高阈值，在经验之后……”玛拉告诉我，这有时会导致有趣的困惑事件。比如有一次哈维走进一家7-11便利店，听到店里各种机器发出的所有电子音。他试图解码它们，因为在他看来它们应该是字母。然后他意识到，不，那只是电子音。那只是收银机。不，那只是电子音。那只是收银机。哈维在7-11的错误向我暗示了一种方式，即我作为盲人读者的未来可能……
Reading entire novels, using what came to be called musical print. It's at the necessary functions of the... Using the devices he tested for the VA, Harvey could read by vibration through musical print, plus Braille and super sped up talking books. He reads using more of his body, more of his senses than perhaps anyone else on the planet. His colleagues called him a cyborg. He walked around with these devices dangling around his neck wherever he went, emitting vibrations and synthetic musical tones.
实际上预示着除了彻底损失之外的其他东西。失明可能会给我的生活增加一些东西，即使它夺走了其他东西。通过新的感官学习以新的方式阅读，可能会增加我对周围世界的欣赏。哈维告诉玛拉，他觉得光音器的电子音调和和弦很美。他说它们让他想起德彪西的音乐，这给了我希望，无论我最终以哪种方式阅读——通过加速的合成语音、布莱叶盲文，或者也许是某种尚未发明的高科技后光音器半机械人系统——我也会在那种阅读中找到美。
I had to turn up the threshold after empirical... Mara told me that this sometimes led to funny incidents of confusion. Like the time Harvey walked into a 7-11 and heard all these electronic tones coming out of the various machines in the store. He tried decoding them because it seemed to him like they should be alphabetic. And then he realized, nope, there's just electronic tones. It's just the cash register. Nope, there's just electronic tones. It's just the cash register. Harvies mistake in the 7-11 suggests to me a way that my future as a blind reader might
“我真的应该用另一副耳机，插上另一个扬声器。假设是什么？用一个更充分的替换它。我以为你要去反驳假设的部分。不一定非要有一个……”接下来，我们的作曲家肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）将为我们上一堂关于用光音器阅读的简短课程，并解析他们使用光音字母为本集创作的音乐。广告之后。所以我现在和肖恩·里亚尔在录音室里。所以故事最后的那首歌是一首与本集相关的特别歌曲。所以你能描述一下你是如何为本集的那个特定部分制作音乐的吗？是的，所以当我们进行剪辑时，每个人都被故事结尾的光音器迷住了。
actually signal something other than a total loss. Blindness could add something to my life, even as it takes something else away. Learning to read in new ways through new senses could increase my appreciation for the world around me. Harvey told Mara that he finds the electronic tones and chords of the optophone beautiful. He said they remind him of Debussy's music, which gives me hope, that whichever way I end up reading, through sped-ups, synthetic speech, or braille, or maybe some high-tech post-optophonic cyborg system that's yet to be invented, that I'll find the beauty in that kind of reading too.
对。在整个那部分，每个人都在说，哇，那种声音简直让人着迷。是的。所以我被它那种音乐性所吸引，我想，如果能把它当作一种乐器来用会很酷。于是我问安德鲁，如果有一种方法可以获取字母的样本，不仅可以用来制作音乐，你知道，像声音一样，
I really should use the other earphones and plug in the other speaker. How are the pothuses? Replace it with a more adequate one. I thought you were to fight the part for hypothesis. There's not necessarily a fuck down the qually. Coming up, our composer, Sean Rial, gives us a short lesson in reading with the optophone and breaks down the music they composed for this episode using optophonic letters. After this. So I'm now in the studio with Sean Rial. So the song at the very end of the story was a special song that were related to the episode. So you can you describe how you made the music for that particular section of the episode? Yeah, so when we were doing our edit, everyone was just so fascinated by the optophone at the end of the story.
而且可以真正拼写出什么，并传达一个信息，让歌曲有歌词，你会怎么说？太酷了。我发现用光音器样本来写作真的很难，稍后我会多谈谈这一点。我想给你放一些这个，因为当我听所有这些不同字母的录音带时，我实际上对它有多直观感到非常震惊。哦，酷。好吧，让我们先听一些。我要做的第一件事是给你放一个O。所以这是一个O。
Right. And throughout that whole section, everyone was just going, wow, and just like the sort of sounds of it were just entrancing. Yeah. And so I was just like taken with how like musical it was, and I was like, this would be a really cool thing to use as an instrument. And so then I asked Andrew, would you say if there was a way to get samples of the alphabet basically to not only like make music out of, you know, like the sounds,
光音器所做的是，它实际上是在扫描文本，所以它基本上是在制作字母的听觉形状。所以O，如果你想到O的左边，你会得到两个非常靠近中间的中音，然后随着圆圈打开，你会得到一个高音和一个低音。然后它们会重新闭合。重新连接。好吧，所以你在中间有两个音调。
but like to actually like spell something out and like make a message, have, you know, lyrics to the song. So cool. I found out that it's very hard to actually write with with optophone Samples and then I'll talk a little bit more about that later I want to play you some of this because when I was listening to the tape of like all these different letters I was really struck actually with how intuitive it is. Oh cool. Okay, so let's hear some first thing I'm going to do is going to play you in oh so here's a no Okay, so let's hear some. First thing I'm going to do is I'm going to play you in O. So here's an O.
然后它向高和低扩展，然后回到中间。这就创造了O的形状。所以你就像扫描印刷字体一样扫描一个字母。是的。所以这是同一个O，但放慢了速度。这样你就能真正听到它了。
What the Optiphone is doing, it's actually scanning text, and so it's basically making an auditory shape of the letter. So the O, if you think of the left of the O, you're going to have two mid-tones, very close to the middle, and then as the circle opens up, you're gonna have a tone that is high and a tone that is low. And then they're gonna close back up. Joins back up. Okay, so you have like two tones in the middle.
好吧。好吧，酷，酷，酷。好吧，我想我明白了。我想我几乎听懂了那个。是的，好吧。所以另一个我认为实际上是最好的字母是W。而且，我想你真的能听出这个。
And then it expands high and low and then goes back down to being in the middle. And that creates the shape of an O. So you're just scanning across a letter as if it's just printed type. Yeah. And so here's that same oh again, but slowed down. So you can really hear it.
然后它向高处和低处扩展，接着又回到中间。这就形成了O的形状。所以你就像在扫描印刷字体一样扫描一个字母。是的。这就是刚才那个O，不过放慢了速度。这样你就能真正听清楚了。
Okay. Okay, cool, cool, cool. Okay, I think I got it. I think I almost got that one. Yeah, okay. So on then another letter that I thought was the best letter actually is a W. And it's all that this one, I think you'll really be able to hear this one
好的。好的，酷，酷，酷。好的，我想我明白了。我想我差不多掌握那个了。是的，好的。那么，另一个我认为最好的字母其实是W。这个字母的所有部分，我想你一定能听出来。
because unlike the O or actually most of the letters in the alphabet, the W doesn't have any like vertical stacking. So it's really just like, you really do like read it left to right. Like there's one point at a time. So like you don't hear two tones simultaneously. So you should be able to trace the W as it goes. High, low, high, low, high. Exactly. Okay. So, here's the W. And then here it is slow down. Yeah, then here it is slow it down.
因为不像字母O，或者实际上不像字母表中的大多数字母，W没有任何垂直堆叠的部分。所以它真的就像是，你确实是从左到右阅读它。就像一次只有一个点。所以你不会同时听到两个音调。因此，你应该能够追踪W的走向。高、低、高、低、高。没错。好的，这就是W。然后这是放慢速度的版本。是的，这是放慢速度的版本。
Okay, do that again. Yeah. What I really love is that you can tell that the midpoint of the W is lower than the other two points than the outside. Right. Oh, that's so interesting. So they're choosing a certain type of W. It doesn't go all the way. It isn't a W where the middle goes all the way to the top line.
好的，再做一次。是的。我真正喜欢的是，你可以看出W的中点比另外两个外侧的点要低。对吧。哦，那太有趣了。所以他们选择了一种特定类型的W。它没有完全上去。这不是那种中间一直延伸到顶线的W。
It's one where it goes in the middle. I'm interested. Yeah, it's extremely specific to whatever font you have, whatever page you're reading. Makes sense, yeah. So, to make the music, I was listening to a lot of raw tape of Harvey Lauer just playing with his optophone and kind of like being odd at it in the same way that we were and so that was and so that was just like so neat and so there's there's like this type of him just reading numbers with it and just like really getting a kick out of it. There's an open four by golly. There's a good five. These are nice numbers. Boy those are nice
它是那种中间凹下去的。我很有兴趣。是的，这完全取决于你使用的字体，以及你正在阅读的页面。有道理，是的。所以，为了制作音乐，我听了很多Harvey Lauer用他的光电阅读器（optophone）演奏的原始录音，就像我们一样对它感到惊奇，这真是太棒了。所以他用它读数字，真的从中得到了很多乐趣。看，一个开放的4，天哪。一个很好的5。这些数字真不错。天哪，这些数字真好。
numbers to read. He developed the octophone so like he's probably the person most fluent in octophone ease in the world. Yeah. But like you said, like this is a scanner that goes across any print that there is. So it's like he's reading a certain display because there sometimes, you know, like I make a seven with a crosshatch through it, for example. And so that would sound different than a normal seven without a crosshatch across the middle of it. Yeah. So even though, you know, he knows the optophone better than anybody, every time it scans a new font, a new typeface,
读起来真好。他开发了光电阅读器，所以他可能是世界上最精通“光电阅读器语”的人。是的。但就像你说的，这是一个可以扫描任何印刷品的扫描仪。所以就像他在阅读特定的显示内容一样，因为有时候，你知道，比如我写一个带交叉线的7。那听起来会和中间没有交叉线的普通7不同。是的。所以即使他比任何人都了解光电阅读器，但每次它扫描一种新字体、一种新字样时，
you get something new from it. He gets something new from it. It's a really enjoying reading. That is so cool. Okay, that's so great. Yeah. So inspired by the optophone, you composed a couple of songs, and one of them was at the end, and it had a message inside of it that was a true optophone
你都会从中得到新的东西。他也会从中得到新的东西。这真的很有趣。太酷了。好的，太棒了。是的，受光电阅读器的启发，你创作了几首歌，其中一首在结尾处，里面包含了一个真正光电阅读器的信息。
message inside of the song. So what did it say? If very true optophone message, it said optophone. And you just say, okay, that's great, because that's the O's, which you can kind of figure out and stuff like that. Oh, yeah. And that's exactly like leading to my next point. Like, I tried out a lot of like different messages, because I originally thought like, oh, I could like have like a whole sentence or something, but I noticed that because these sounds are coming just one letter at a time, It was actually really like melodically important. I found to have multiple letters that repeat. So, your optophone actually kind of has a pattern to it. It's O-P-T-O-P-H-O-N-E, and so it's like, and so actually every three letters is an O.
歌曲里的信息。那么它说了什么？如果是一个非常真实的光电阅读器信息，它说的是“optophone”。你只会说，好的，那太棒了，因为那是O，你可以大概猜出来之类的。哦，是的。这正好引出了我的下一个观点。我尝试了很多不同的信息，因为我最初想，哦，我可以写一整句话之类的，但我注意到因为这些声音是一个字母一个字母发出来的，在旋律上其实非常重要。我发现让多个字母重复出现很有必要。所以，你的光电阅读器实际上有一种模式。它是O-P-T-O-P-H-O-N-E，所以实际上每三个字母就是一个O。
And so... it takes on the characteristic of music because of that. Okay. So let's remind people of the little section of I'm so cool. Sounds so good. Could you hear the letters? I totally could. I mean, you had to tell me what it was before I heard it, but, you know, I understood it a little bit. This is so amazing.
所以……它因此具有了音乐的特性。好的。那么让我们提醒大家刚才那段小节。听起来真不错。你能听到那些字母吗？我完全能听到。我是说，你得先告诉我那是什么我才能听出来，但是，你知道，我稍微理解了一点。这太神奇了。
Thank you so much. And I'm so pleased that you created music inspired by the Octophone. It was so much fun to do. I really, yeah, I really like appreciated being inspired to do this. Cool. OK, let's hear the last song in. We'll go out. 1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5-1.5- That little bit of Octophone, says 99% invisible. 99% invisible was Was Produced This Week by Andrew Leeland and edited by Delaney Hall.
非常感谢。我很高兴你创作了受光电阅读器启发的音乐。做这件事真的很有趣。我真的，是的，我真的很感激能受到启发来做这件事。酷。好的，让我们听听最后一首歌，然后结束。那一点点光电阅读器的声音，这就是99% Invisible。本周的99% Invisible由Andrew Leeland制作，Delaney Hall编辑。
Mixed in Tech Production by Sriviusif, Music by Sean Reale. Katie Mingle is the senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. Thrust the team is Avery Trollman, Vivian Lee, Joe Rosenberg, and Mithett Sheryl, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Many thanks this week to Sorry Outchooler and David Weimer. We found out about the story of Boston Line Type from an exhibition they put together called Touch This Page. The exhibition is also online at touchthispage.com where you can see examples of Boston Line Type
技术制作由Sriviusif负责，音乐由Sean Reale创作。Katie Mingle是高级制作人，Kurt Colstead是数字总监。团队成员还有Avery Trollman、Vivian Lee、Joe Rosenberg、Mithett Sheryl、Sophia Klatsker，以及我Roman Mars。本周非常感谢Sorry Outchooler和David Weimer。我们从他们策划的名为“触摸这一页”（Touch This Page）的展览中了解到了波士顿线体（Boston Line Type）的故事。该展览也可以在touchthispage.com在线查看，在那里你可以看到波士顿线体的示例
and other precursors to Braille. Special thanks also to Jen Hale and Jennifer Arnott at the Perkins School, Matthew Rubrie of Queen Mary University of London, whose book about the history of talking books is awesome, and Walid Malise from North Eastern's College of Engineering. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of Israel is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting.
以及其他盲文的前身。还要特别感谢Perkins学校的Jen Hale和Jennifer Arnott，伦敦玛丽女王大学的Matthew Rubrie，他关于有声读物历史的书非常棒，以及东北大学工程学院的Walid Malise。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的Radio Row制作。99% Invisible是来自PRX的Radiotopia成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。
Find them all at radiotopia.evm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI or on Instagram and read it too. But you need to run to our website and see video of the spectrogram of the Octophone letters that Sean composed is so cool. That's at 99PI.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在radiotopia.fm上可以找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI，或者在Instagram和Reddit上关注。但你需要访问我们的网站，观看Sean创作的光电阅读器字母的频谱图视频，那太酷了。网址是99PI.org。Radiotopia。来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。